you know hitler spoke to
he could speak things like inflation
right which really existed
um but he also appealed to
the irrational emotions of germans right
he
sought out scapegoats you know jews
roma um disabled people homosexuals and
so on right and that's also
there in bin laden too i mean daddy of
um
you know a an anti-semitism
uh the constant flagging of zionists and
crusaders it's a kind of shotgun
approach to
a search for followers but i also hated
to add that it's
for all of the
things that we could take off saying
well yes kashmiris have suffered
chechens have suffered and so on um
bin ladenism
never became a mass movement i mean it
never really
i think the
i mean this is the encouraging thing
right about
ideology i mean i think the
the blood on his hands always limited
his appeal
among muslims and others
um
but milan did have i mean he had a
there's a great book by um a great
scholar at uc san diego um
jeremy prestol who wrote a great book
about global icons in which uh he has
bin laden
he has um
bob marley
he has
tupac
you know he asked why
you know when he's doing research
in east africa why did he see young kids
wearing bin laden shirts
they're also wearing like tupac shirts
they're wearing bob marley shirts and
bass it's a way of looking at um
a kind of partial
embrace of some aspects of
the rebelliousness of
some of these figures some of the time
by some people under certain conditions
well the terrifying thing to me so yeah
there is a longing in the human heart to
belong to a group and a charismatic
leader somehow
especially when you're young
just a catalyst for all of that and
i tend to think
that perhaps it's actually hard to be
hitler so a leader so charismatic that
he can rile a nation to war
and bin laden perhaps were lucky
was not sufficiently charismatic
i i feel like if his writing was better
if his speeches were better
if his ideas were stronger
better it's like uh more viral
and then there will be more people
kind of
young people uniting around him so in
some sense
it's almost like accidents of history of
just how much charisma
how much charisma a particular evil
person has
personally like bin laden
i think it's fair he will evil works i
think do you think bin laden is evil oh
yeah yeah i mean he was a mass murderer
um
i'm just saying that his ideas were
they're more complex than than we've
tended to acknowledge um they had
they have a wider potential resonance
than we would acknowledge i mean and
also i guess what i'm the just
one fundamental point is that um
thinking about the complexity of bin
laden is also a way of
removing him from islam
he is not an islamic thinker he is a
cosmopolitan thinker who
plays in all kinds of modern ideologies
which have proven to mobilize people in
the past right so
know anti-semitism
um populism environmentalism and the
kind of in the the urging to like
you know do something about humanity do
something about suffering that's why i
think the actual yes about like what
motivates people to do this kind of
stuff i think that's why if one goes
below the level of leadership
and this is being reported if you look
at the
trial ongoing now in paris of
uh the bataclan
murders i think um
the court allowed some discussion of the
backgrounds of the accused and they come
from
different backgrounds but if there's any
common bond it's kind of that they
have some background in petty crime
famously in the seven seven bombings in
london
the
metropolitan police you know uk
authorities looked at all those guys
and
what people want is this idea that like
they must be very pious they must be you
know super islamic to do this kind of
stuff
they must be fanatical true believers
but
what they found with those guys was that
some were
nominally muslim
some went to mosques some didn't
some were single young guys with like
criminal backgrounds
some
you know we're like sorry they were
you know kind of misfits who never
succeeded in anything
but others had you know at least one
thing had a wife and family who he you
know widowed and orphaned
and so there's no i mean for policing i
mean if you're looking at that lens
there is no kind of typology that will
predict
who will become violent that's why i
think we have to move beyond thinking
about religious augmentation narrowly or
by itself
and think about things like geopolitics
think about
how people respond to inequality
you know the the existential threat of
cri of you know climate crisis
of um a whole host of matters of and and
think about th this is a mode of
political contestation i mean it's a
violent one it's when i condemn it is
evil right
but these are people that are they're
trying to be political they're trying to
change things in some way
it's not nearly about like i want to
impose sharia law on you
you must wear a veil
you must eat this kind of food it's it's
not that parochial but one another quick
thought about your
interesting claim about charisma in this
i think that the
one self-limiting feature
of this subculture is that
definitely you know i mentioned the
enigma of not wanting to be seen and
that the
kind of
invisibility
is a productive force of power
you know which
a colleague of mine who knows ancient
history far better than i
you know said this is you know when she
looked at
malomar initially or we come up bin
laden i mean this kind of studied
posture of staying in the shadows
yeah it's also a source of authority
potentially because it it um
it invites the idea and it's probably
dictatorships to do as well i mean it
advises the idea that someone's working
and maybe it's the it's the basis for a
lot of q anon or other conspiracy today
that someone's working behind the scenes
and things are going to go the right way
you can't see it
that's almost preferable because
you can kind of feel it
and so
not having someone out front
can maybe maybe more effective than
having someone out in front constantly
maybe and then the whole bin laden you
know omar thing like you can't see me or
if you look at you know bin laden's
photographs and his video stuff
i mean he's
he's coy
uh some observers have noted he's kind
of effeminate he doesn't strike this
kind of masculine
he's not a mussolini he's not a hitler
macho i'm standing my thumping my chest
he's not doing the theatrical chin you
know
the theater people tell us is so
aggressive um
you know oh chin just what bringing your
chin up oh i saw a great uh bbc theater
person it was kind of a
it was a makeover show about how to
become a better creator oh no uh just a
powerful
uh yeah leader authoritarian figure no
just how to how to like get ahead in
life and then oh okay cool and just like
about acting like how you can act
differently right so it was it was a bbc
thing um
and this woman claimed that um
you know sticking your chin out like a
wrestler does right is the most like
male demand i love this kind of mustache
hilarious analysis that people have
about
power but watch the chin watch the chin
it's the same as analyzing like in
wrestling
styles that win or fighting or so on
there's so many ways well the chan i
mean the chan is a could be
an interesting verbal gesture and i uh
i've watched enough mussolini footage
for my classes to try to pick the right
moment and the chin is muslin is all
about the chin so and i have watched
human beings and human nature enough to
know that there's more to a man a
powerful man than a chin yeah no no no
no
i'm saying it's an act of aggression i'm
not saying it's it's one of the many
tools in the toolkit yeah yeah sure so
yeah
it's not all about the channel but it's
it's uh but that's what i'm trying to
tell you about bin laden i don't think
he was
deliberate enough
with the way he presents himself so he
what i'm saying about bin laden that
makes him different from these other
characters is that
because he
played it being the scholar
he played it being a figure of modesty
and humility and that meant that he was
often
again if you watch his visuals i mean
yes there's one video of him firing a
gun
but if you watch how he moved
how he wouldn't look at people directly
how his face was almost
i mean he appears to be incredibly shy
he saw spoken
you know his voice was low
he attempted to be poetic
right so it wasn't a warrior kind of
image that he tried to project of like a
tough guy
it was i'm i'm newer i'm humble
i'm in you know i'm i'm offering this
message and that
the appeal that he was going for was
to see um
to protect himself as a scholar
his knowledge
and humility the whole package carried
with it an authenticity
and a valor
that would animate
inspire people to commit acts of
violence right and it's a different kind
of like logic of like yes go and kill
right so he he put he presented himself
in contrast to the imperialist
yeah yeah so that's just yet another way
of uh yeah and you have to have facial
hair or hair of different kind that's
recognized we had a very recognizable
look too or at least later in life
yeah no he he tried to look apart um
yeah yeah but i'm saying we're fortunate
that whatever right calculation that he
was making he was not more
um
effective yet i mean there's the the
world is full of terrorist organizations
and we're fortunate
to the degree any one of them does not
have an incredibly charismatic leader
that attains the kind of power that's
very difficult to
to manage at the geopolitical level yeah
we and we credit we credit the publics
you know who don't you don't bind to
that right you see through this we
credit the the critics you know um
barely on premise 9 11 itself
one of the problems was that
u.s government officials kept kind of
leaning on muslims to
to condemn this as if
all muslims shared some collective
responsibility or culpability
and in fact um
dozens of scholars and organizations
hundreds condemn this but their
condemnations never quite made it out
but it created a tension where
you know if you wore a veil
you must been one of them and you must
be on team bin laden and so a lot of the
you know i think a lot of the popular
violence and discrimination and and
profiling came out of that urge to
see a oneness
which you know been like bin laden
projected right he wanted to say we are
one community you know if you are a
muslim you must be with me right
but i think that
that's where the the diversity of muslim
communities became important because
outside of small pockets i mean they
didn't they didn't accept his leadership
right
people wore t-shirts in some countries i
mean non-muslims were teachers because
he was like he stuck it to the americans
so
in latin america people are like yeah
that was sad but
you know finally i mean there was a kind
of shot in florida in that moment yeah
it's like guevara or somebody like that
yeah change the other character in uh
yeah yeah that's right that's right yeah
it's just a symbol it's not exactly what
he believed exactly or the cruelty of
actions he took right it's more like he
stood for an idea of
revolution versus authority that's right
and that's and that's
a great way to understand bin ladenism
and the whole phenomenon but i think
looking at the big picture it's also
you wonder
without ever end right i mean is that i
mean that's the the risk of being a kind
of hyperpower
um like the us where you
in in insisting on kind of unipolar
world
in 2001 2002 2003
i mean that created
an almost irresistible target
you know wherever the u.s wanted to
exert itself militarily
you